[Music]
so yeah was I was going through a lot of
viewers games there was one guy Sam the
beast who actually played a very
interesting game but unfortunately his
opponents moves weren't optimal so I
chose to choose to look at this one
because I think there's some interesting
strategical topics we can discuss some
interesting ideas for both sides some
swings you know in in assessment
throughout the game but overall I'm
quite an interesting interesting battle
so with that being said white hexagon
versus no greatness d4 Knight f6 c4 e6
wait should we put this on training
let's put it on training is six Knight
c3 bishop before okay how is this
opening cold yes yes yes don't even the
names oh then that the name is though I
think Queen's Indian is with b6 with
Bishop before included but yeah at the
moment I think we should just call it
the names Oh Queen to c2 and now I think
already black made a slight inaccuracy
he took on c3 immediately which doesn't
really make a lot of sense I think we
should wait for for for why to provoke
that move with a3 lose a tempo in the
meantime and also whenever you're
playing a three very often you're
weakening the light squares especially
this guy on b3 and black has this extra
option extra idea of playing a5 a4 in
certain situations and actually blocking
the pawn on b2 so taking on c3 directly
doesn't really make a lot of sense it
doesn't make sense at all actually
it's just a lot of tempo you're giving
your Bishop air for no reason unprovoked
and white is going to enjoy a very
stable long-term advantage in the
upcoming moves and middlegame so Bishop
takes c3 I think one of the main lines
is castle
there is also c5 in this position taking
advantage of the fact that the queen is
not on the D file anymore not supporting
d5 plenty plenty of ideas d5 I think is
also an option d6 a lot a lot of moves
but Bishop c3 is definitely not one of
them so whenever you have the option of
taking this type of exchanging decisions
make sure I mean if they're unprovoked
ask yourself do I actually have to do it
you know if they are provoked then of
course you're going to have to take a
decision at that moment but black didn't
have to do it right now
94 to be honest I think his thought
process was that basically huge just
wasn't prepared against Queen c2 and he
wanted to obtain some sort of blocade
some some sort of grip on this light
squares in the center so right now for
example if you go castle I can also play
4 which is not a very good move to be
honest it's not a good move at all
because after Bishop takes c3 you have
to take back with the b-pawn and then
okay maybe I can go c5 actually I might
even be able to go c5 directly or d5
your pawns and your structure is a
little bit loose but I think black
simply just didn't want to allow this
central expansion by white so that's why
he took Bishop takes c3 and forcefully
planted the knight in the center the
problem is that that Knight is not going
to have such long life there you know
I'm going to be able to just take it out
with a move such as f3 in the
future it's it's not that difficult
actually so he play 94 Queen c2 f5 of
course Knight to f3
another inaccuracy I would say I I think
I should I should play something like
III first I don't want to commit my
knight to a certain position immediately
because I want to have this extra option
I want to play Bishop d3 92 and f3 and I
want to take your night away and after
that I'm going to find a placement for
this Bishop potentially after if or
after you move your night I'm going to
play a 4 and then Bishop b3 or something
like that or the second option would be
to play b4 and Bishop b2 depending on
how you are going to arrange your pieces
but these are the type of knight of
trees I would say a very natural
automatic move automatic developing move
which sometimes is not the best option
so always always assess your
possibilities because very often you
will you will find quite interesting
ideas that perhaps you're not thinking
about naturally and I mean I understand
the fact that he didn't want to play III
immediately because he didn't want to
close up his Bishop but I think III
Bishop d3 night e 2 keeping that square
for the knight f3 is important and I
think white would have had a very very
strong advantage after Knight of 3 is
going to be a little bit more difficult
to take the night away from the center
the night from efore Castle III Knight
to c6
that's not the most natural placement
for the night either generally you want
to play D 6b 6b should be seven nine
poops this night goes to d7 generally
potentially to f6 and then supporting
the other night only for nineteen no
knight on c6 is also possible the
problem is he is not going to have a
bright future afterwards and he's also
going to accommodate this Bishop on ca
because whenever I put it on b7 which is
its natural position in this type of
structure this diagonal is cropped right
with the knight on c6 that's why you
want to keep the Knight to d7 I don't
like this 96 obviously he's fighting
against the natural Bishop d3 because
right now after night before white would
have some problems right but right
before is easy to stop and I don't even
have to put my Bishop to d3 that's not
necessarily how I'm going to carry out
the plan of evicting your knife from e4
usually I'm going to play Bishop e2
Castle move the knight and then F 3 once
again but he played a3 with the idea to
play Bishop b3 b6 Bishop d3 and now the
knight has to go back yeah you're not in
time to defend that night that's why
knight c6 was just the loss of tempo you
should have played b6 and B should be 7
to try to defend that night as for as
long as possible
Knight to g5 before very aggressive very
aggressive you I mean natural plant
generally the problem is there's a clear
problem somebody from the audience maybe
can try to explain it to me
clear strategical problem and what
should have been done in this position
for white from White's perspective and
it's not complicated at all it's very
very straightforward yes do something
about it yeah not leave it there hanging
because after b4 knight takes f3 I I
think this was played the white
structure White's damaged structure is
is probably going to give black the
advantage I think white wasn't just
simply a very aggressive player to be
honest and he predicted this type of
position and he was going to play as in
the game we should be too long castle
and try to make use of the open G file
the problem is from an objective point
of view the position is not very good so
in this position he should have just
played natural moves such as play for
for the long-term
because white has a very very powerful
advantage and that is strategical
advantage hmm he has some space here
yeah
more pieces developed I don't know about
that no I don't think he has more pieces
developed actually I think they're more
or less black is already castled
I mean the Queen on sea talk you can say
is developed or not I mean from D 1 is
also potentially developed because I'm
defending the f3 Knight but no that's
not his biggest Trump biggest advantage
in the position nope it's a very typical
advantage for this opening it's a
long-term advantage it's not the
initiative yes thank you
the bishop are of course long-term
advantage yeah
the bishop er yeah it's it's an
advantage that in order to achieve a
certain level of chess understanding you
kind of have to tackle it you know very
often people underestimate the bishop er
but I think it's a very very valuable
strategical Trump and if you can take it
and if you can handle it well and if you
can hold it in certain positions then
most probably you're going to be able to
build a very powerful powerful advantage
so before is a mistake he should have
just simply taken on g5 2085 short
castle they should be seven and now
maybe just f3 close the diagonal is very
important not to get checkmated
obviously and then I can go before
Bishop d2
build my space advantage on the
queenside you're simply not going to
have any sort of counter play on the
kingside and slowly slowly i'm going to
start pushing your pieces back if you
move this night maybe at the right time
I'm even going to try to open up the
center with E for and then block your
Bishop with d5 potentially I can tell
you from my own experience these
positions this type of structures and
black fighting against the bishop pair
is very very unpleasant so he played
before not understanding the plan
now it takes F 3 G takes f 3 Bishop to
b7 Bishop b2 again I mean he was kind of
playing to his own style and his own
style is obviously very aggressive he
just wants to checkmate his opponent the
problem is strategically is not very
sound Knight to e7 e 4f takes c4 F takes
c4 and we reach this position what
should black do right I think this is
what black did in the position yeah
attack the queenside interesting that's
that's definitely something that could
could come up night yeah Knight to g6 of
forks I mean I I doze weak squares weak
dark scores on on the King side yeah
King side castle is not possible because
Knight f4 Queen g5 that some checkmates
will come on the board very quickly so
you kind of have to go on the King side
on the Queen side sorry this is what he
did and now I think he made a mistake if
I'm not mistaken let's see what he did
yes he played a move d5 which I
certainly don't understand what I do
kind of understand he's trying to block
the bishop on b2 but in the same time
he's also blocking the bishop on b7 and
more importantly you're giving me the
option of opening this diagonal what
should have been played by black a few
options
a few candidate moves tied up to some
some plans I would like to know when to
g5 is surely one of them but that's
simply just a check right are we doing
anything after that
so Queen g5 King H King b1 generally
that I mean in this especially in this
situation the threat is more unpleasant
than the execution yeah and we have to
leave that check in the air yeah the
King on c1 is a little bit uncomfortable
and he's going to have to lose the
temple with King b1 we shouldn't force
him to lose that temple
why wouldn't we play this move first
then go into h4 it attacks the f2 pond
it also stops white from expanding with
the move h4 and overall is taking
control over the dark squares on the
kingside which is extremely important
strategically black is definitely better
white does have some potential for for
for dynamics in the position if he
manages to open up his bishops but it's
going to be very difficult to to do that
black is just playing with with tempo
tempo tempo tempo maybe play if you go
something like root D to I can even go
something like rook f3 yet go rook f8
block your position there block your
position on the King side not allow you
to to create any counter play and then
slowly slowly my strategical Trump's
should play a huge part and win the game
so instead of that he played a move d5
which I certainly don't find very
appealing and not very clever huh he's
bearing the bishop on b7 he's also
bearing the bishop on b2 which I would
assume that was kind of his overall plan
at least return idea but yeah more
importantly he's blocking his own Bishop
and he's also allowing me to play e5 at
the right moment and open up this
important diagonal that's going to allow
me to create a lot of counter play so in
this position I think white kind of
returned the favor a little bit and
played played an inaccuracy of his own I
think C takes d5 did he play this no he
played he takes d5 first I think C takes
d5 we
have been better it 65 ET xt5 and then
if I absolutely I think if I've is
enough that passed pawn in the center is
going to be extremely powerful now
opening up the the b1 h7 diagonal is
also very influential and I think white
is starting to be better okay already
wrote the g1 is coming of course white
still has his own problems like the
bishop on b2 and potentially after an
exchange of this bishop with the knight
on g6 obviously the remaining pieces are
probably going to favor black the
remaining opposite color bishops because
black is going probably going to be able
to activate it via a 6 C 4 or even c 8 f
5 after the exchange of these two pieces
so even if you gain a pawn as white
you're still going to have some problems
strategically yeah nevertheless it's
it's a much better position than what he
had a few moves ago when he was almost
losing I mean after Castle if he if he
plays Queen h4 I think objectively is
losing so he played D 5 e takes d5
very similar position to to the one with
the pawn on e5 but we just don't have
the pawn on e5 in his position so we
have the pawn on c4 which is a a worse
version a clearly worse version rook to
g1 night - f yeah this was a very
strange move so white is not really
threatening anything besides just
winning upon on g6 which he could have
done I think at this moment as well so
we play this move rook g1 and Knight f4
no now Knight aphorism is is a clear
mistake
the knight is not going to do anything
on that for the knight is not going to
play such a huge part in your attack and
you're just simply giving me a pawn I
think what black should have understood
is that he wants the exchange of the
bishop on d3 with the knight on g6
eliminate the bishop er leave white with
the bad bishop on b2 and okay I'm going
to lose a pawn but that's not going to
be the end of the world
yeah the ensuing position with opposite
opposite color bishops and heavy pieces
on the board
well actually whenever we have opposites
opposite color bishops and heavy pieces
on the board which are the two main
factors of assessment
who has the initiative absolutely that's
one of them and the second most
important I mean depending on the
position that kind of plays a part into
the initiative into the initiative
factor yeah king safety if your king is
not safe then you're probably in trouble
the difference between the bishops so
who has the initiative and which bishop
is better in this case probably this
bishop on b7 is going to be better
because once again is going to be much
easier to get to your king and his MA is
going to be much easier to get him
active so actually after Queen h4 I
think black still has the advantage for
the simple fact that the structure is
just intolerable for white it's terrible
very ugly structure so unfortunately
Knight f4 came as a surprise to me no
greatness played played not so great
right Bishop takes h7 King h8 King be
one good prophylaxis the King on c1 was
definitely quite unstable so on b1 is
much more safe and this is a good move
or a bad move D takes c4 looks bad but
why the question is why and if it is bad
then we have to punish it absolutely
this move just simply loses on the spot
after d5 you can basically resign I mean
you're opening up my monster you got
greedy you try to take get your pawn
back because I cannot take on c4 because
your Bishop on h7 is hanging the problem
is this d5 is just killing game over
finito no as
at all costs you should have tried to
stop me from opening my dark square
bishop so no greatness not very
well-played it never opened your Europe
ponens strongest piece I guess that
could be made a rule night D trip and
now we're just going to see some
checkmates coming on the board nice
little sacrifice but obviously the king
is completely naked C takes D 323 and
checkmates are coming on the board Queen
a 526 king of fade route to g8 and
that's all she wrote
okay very interesting game strategically
flawed tactically quite quite sharp
white you know pounded pounded blacks
position when he had the opportunity
strategically not not very sound but it
happens anyway an interesting game let's
go to the second one I have another one
prepared for this lesson
I think the player as black submitted it
Phillip something I don't I don't know
who he's playing it's not written and
you were around here at the end so I
think it's Phillip as black so Phillip
if you're watching this know that we're
watching your game alright so let's see
4 d 5 e 5e t XD 5 obviously is the main
line and list the Scandinavian a 5 and
our black played is 6 which I think it's
already I mean an inaccuracy why would
we play a 6
why would we go into a French without
getting our bishop out without getting
our light-square bishop which is the bad
bishop in the French out right let's
compare it to the CARICOM immediately
Bishop e5 Bishop f5 comes on the board
we can get the same thing basically
after D v e5 Bishop f5 and let's say
white is going to go d4 now very often
in the CARICOM the pawn from c6 actually
goes to c5 and he's losing what time one
temple in this particular case we can
play his six and then next move plays c5
we're not losing a temple yeah so we're
basically playing a favorable version of
the caracal that's why for whitey five
is just a mistake you should accept the
Scandinavian play it takes d5 Quinn
takes d5 or Knight f6 grab grab the
space advantage in the center and just
play a long game if five is not the
right solution and a six is another in
accuracy well right now we just have a
typical French typical advanced French
unfortunately if I remember correctly
black played the bad move here 96
the best movies see five of course we're
attacking the pawn chain right right
acting the pawn chain were grabbing some
space on the queenside as black white is
going to have space advantage on the
kingside so it's going to be a battle
between the expansion blacks expansion
on the queenside whites the expansion on
the Kings side and trying to checkmate
the black King I'm just going to try to
break through with my pieces on the
Queen side as black of course you know
there is a there's a lot of theory going
on you know the theory goes all the way
to like move 2025 at top level and most
of them are quite forced 96 just doesn't
make a lot of sense
because right now you're not going to be
able you're going to have difficulties
gaining gaining control over over the
Queen side and creating your own counter
play and you're just going to have to
suffer because of whites space advantage
on the Kings side
so after 96 white is just simply better
Bishop to b4 another very strange move
you're basically just helping me create
my my pawn chain you know but he played
Bishop d2 which I don't agree with I
would play c3 in this position I would
play c3 then put my Bishop on e3 despite
the fact that this Bishop is more or
less closed it could potentially play a
very important role in the future
because at some point I'm going to start
my expansion on the Queen on the King
side and I'm going to create a lot of
holes a lot of dark square holes so this
Bishop on e3 despite the fact that it's
locked for the moment it has a very
bright future
in what position it's check yeah yeah
yeah
black checked on a bishop before and now
Bishop d2 or c3 and also I mean
technically c3 should be a better a
better response because who has the
space advantage white do we want to
exchange pieces when we have space
advantage no we want to keep as many
pieces as possible on the board because
it's going to be more difficult for our
opponent to maneuver his pieces she has
less space and if he has more pieces
than he has even less space so as a rule
in general whenever you have space
advantage you don't want to exchange
pieces that's why I would keep the
bishop on c1 and further on e3
okay he played Bishop d2 97 ah okay we
keep the very good good move c3 is a
very good move of course black should
have taken only d2 immediately and then
play Knight to e7 or try to attack and
open the position with f6 actually I
think that's what he should just go
something like this and f6 attack the
pawn on e5 take advantage of the fact
that after he takes f6 which I'm not
sure it's forced I don't think it's
first Knight takes f6 Knight c3 to
defend against 94 and then somehow he
has to make a 5 work somehow he has to
play e5 as soon as possible and if he
manages to do that in in a favorable
situation then the position is going to
be very very close to equality Oh black
almost equalized
despite his very shady play what both
sides kind of played shady well not so
white played
except a 5 which at move number to
accept that everything was fine and
Bishop d2 c3 which should have been a
much better move
so 97 c3 Bishop a5 now black I think is
borderline close I lost before white has
space advantage on both sides that's
terrible news for black very very very
difficult position b5 again unprovoked
unprovoked change of structure when
these pawns on on the dark squares are
controlling the bishop so well why would
you put your bishop why would you put
your pond or no light square and
actually allowing my knight to jump on
the important C 4 square absolutely no
reason so if you really wanted to play
b5 at some point you should have waited
for for black to provoke it with a 5
once again wait for your opponent to
provoke changes before you engage in
them structural changes generally cannot
be taken back so you have to be
extremely careful with them in this
situation you have much more important
things to do in the position Bishop d3
for example
develop your pieces castle and start
your pawn store I would say Bishop d3
the Knight g5 4 and so on
right you have to you have to move fast
and if black plays a 5 then sure you're
probably going to have to play b5 but as
we can see he also took his square away
from the knight he doesn't have 95
anymore he cannot get to this night C 4
square so he is still having huge huge
problems getting his pieces out b5 big
inaccuracy even the computer says big in
accuracy o best move was Bishop d3 ok I
didn't even read that I do I'm thinking
like the computer I'm in good shape
Castle Bishop d3
Knight to f5
okay I would play h4g for here let's see
what you played I think g4g 4 is
interesting
ah yeah Age 4 was the move
I guess play them of Queenie - wait but
we need to allows 93 right or even a 6
no night b3 makes a lot of sense
whoa what is this
h4 what about the rook yes
so after age for the rook was lost and I
think the game was soon lost we will see
in just a second no but what is Queen e2
doing nothing absolutely nothing you
have to play according to your plan you
have to to abide by a certain plan you
know you cannot play one move there one
move according to that plan one move
according to the other plan
you kind of need some you know some
course of action in your thought process
and in this position Queen e2 just
doesn't make a lot of sense
I thought about h4 because initially I
want to play g4 and expand on the
kingside the problem with g4 is that it
allows night h4 very often whenever we
have the knight on f5 coin on d8 this is
a kind of a well known and studied
pattern I'm going to be able to stop
your expansion by placing that night on
h4
so that's why I want to play h4 first
and then my threat is g4 push your
knight back gain even more space and
ultimately I'm just simply going to
crush you with my pawns
slowlyslowly crusher with the pawns your
king is going to be in big big trouble
and you don't have any counter play well
that's actually it's actually not that
true because you play this move b5 which
is where it was a bad move and now
Knight c4 might come on the board so
it's not as easy for white but certainly
h4 should be the right move Queen e2 was
played Knight B 3 H 4
terrible move watch your watcher pieces
yeah don't forget about rooks now I take
say 1 h5 ok
valiant effort try to attack on the King
side you have to do something you have
to create some sort of counter play
I mean why just lost a lot of material
so if he doesn't find the counter play
then he's going to be able to resign in
no time
Knight to b3 why Bishop perform why
Bishop f4
why not G for now it seems like white
started thinking about which exchanges
are better the problem is that he was
afraid of knighting z2 I would assume
probably is I would pay g4 and even if
you take on D - I'm going to take with
the Queen and then my queen is going to
be able to come towards the towards the
potential potentially weak dark squares
yeah so for example just just to give
you an example Knight to e7 to defend
the night and right now maybe I can play
something like h6 and then Queen f4 and
try to need to play Queen f6 suddenly
you don't have any space for the night
right so actually I did get some sort of
counter play I guess as white I think
the best move in this position is to
play sound like f5 ok I'm going to take
this and still is not game over yeah
because this night is just doesn't have
any squares black is struggling a little
bit with his pace but time time
efficiency is extremely important if you
start playing move such as Bishop f4 and
you allow me to rearrange my pieces find
squares for for them then you're just
going to be a rope down yeah
you have to remember the material
situation and assess what you have to do
based on that so he played bishop at 4f6
bad move
why is it a bad move well mistake okay I
mean it says mistake here but I wouldn't
call it a mistake I would definitely not
call it a mistake I don't see the
reputation I don't see the immediate
reputation I would assume the computer
annotated it as a mistake because
there's simply just a much better option
in the position nevertheless even after
f6 black is completely winning he's a
rock up he's a rock up yeah yeah yeah I
mean he's completely winning since white
decided to give away his roof for no
reason on a 1g for another huge mistake
according to this well okay yeah F takes
F takes t5 I guess was just winning yeah
that makes a lot of sense because why is
if they actually why is f takes if I
have a good move
why is f takes e5 a good move and not
997 I think 97 is a sign a question mark
of course the position is still winning
but as as the annotation point out I
think ethics e5 is better but the
question is why so why is that a good
move in comparison with Knight d7 yes
let's just go along with the most
probable course of action which would be
I would say Bishop takes e5 that's an
interesting move could even be the bad
the best move in the position I don't
know the exact objective evaluation and
I yeah maybe 90 she's good what I was
thinking is Knight d6 but similar idea
yeah I just want to put either my knight
on f7 to defend to defend my king side
or just put the knight on e4 sacrifice a
pawn eliminate some pieces eliminate
some of your important attackers and
then just enjoy my extra rook yeah yeah
but I do like my th6 a little bit better
because I wasn't really sure what to do
against h6
I was a little bit afraid of this move
ah ah very interesting I'm I'm I'm
afraid I'm very scared I'm very very
scared now it's too late I think now
it's too late it way too much counter
bleep we cannot allow that that's why I
don't like 96 actually that's why I
think night 96 or even nights you want
here why shouldn't we play 91 here
very good consequence of the move Bishop
takes d5 the C 1 square is no longer
protected so 91 is an extra option
absolutely we play Knight C 1 we
exchange on D 3 then we reroute the
night when wherever we want I would say
96 924 since that's a newly available
square for us and the position is
completely willing so yes f2 xt5 was
better 97 was played black is still
winning Queen c2
I mean at this point yeah whatever the
computer is saying in accuracy white
cannot really make a lot of inaccuracies
he's lost he just he needs to find some
sort of initiative f5 f5 Wow
giving the night just like that is that
good ah yeah it is good it is good
yeah this is a very bad move I think I
think that takes g4 just simply kills
the game because one of the pieces is
going to be lost not sure why what black
was afraid of
I would assume he was afraid of
something like 95 but after Luke takes a
before okay you take my opponent h7
nevertheless I don't think you have much
more than that
maybe I can go King f8 or even King h8
hmm not sure I think both of them work
because the rook is guarding yeah the
rook is guarding and I'm actually
thinking of bringing my queen to f8 try
to create some active plan of my own I
yeah I don't I don't see how wide can I
improve his position the absence of the
dark square bishop is very influential
so no after I take g4 the game is just
simply over play the move a six it's too
slow yeah you just lost a piece on b3
mm-hmm so after ethics before in this
position that's a good that's a good
question I will take that
mmm-hmm and then I'm going to run away
Quincy too and I'm going to block that
attack of yours I have this option of
just simply blocking maybe I can even
take don't get greedy just block the
attack and that's it game over yeah he's
not doing anything his night is far away
from the center of the action he cannot
bring his bigger the biggest strongest
attacker in the game and if he plays
something like h6 I think I can just
simply respond with g6 okay I'll let you
put your porn on h7 but after King f8 um
hmm thank you for the protection of
course I have some weak dark squares but
the problem is you cannot really take
advantage of them at least I don't see
how and night at night f7 is protected
the night on g5 doesn't have any work to
go and I only need a couple of moves to
get my pieces out and I'm going to enjoy
my extra material so
where were we ah that was your question
but good as white probably you should
try to think about this type of ideas of
course such as Bishop takes h7 create
counter play at all costs
otherwise you're just do I mean you're
doomed anyway but maybe you can create
some sort of confusion in the position
so keep a six again not not not really
playing according to plan you're playing
on on two flanks you played the f5 with
an obvious idea behind it to take on g4
and now after he took your he took your
knight he he's no longer down material
as much material as he was before he's
only an exchange down and now you're not
taking on g4 trying to regain that piece
back you're playing a6 too slow way too
slow Queen to c2 okay mm-hmm ATX b5 a
takes b5 I would yeah I don't I don't
have the engine next to me but I would
take on the air on b5 as well Bishop d7
g5 okay h6 very bad move oh yes
absolutely
very bad yh6
your position is perfectly finally your
position is perfectly safe finally as
black you have absolutely nothing to
worry on the kingside if he plays h6 you
play g6 if you play if he plays g6 you
play h6 you have absolutely nothing to
worry right now all you need to worry is
about opening up the queenside instead
of that you decide to play h6 not good
not good
I see panic written all over this you
know suddenly you see the spawns
advancing in front of you and you kind
of start panicking no reason to panic
whenever you have these points like this
facing each other
again whenever he moves one point you
push the other and you close the
position completely and you just want to
play on the kings on the Queen side yep
that's where your superior pieces are
you're rockin a8 he doesn't have a look
on the a file and so on so h6g takes h6
g6 yeah i mean white is starting to to
feel better to feel like he's better a
little bit and now comes a big blunder
and I g5 okay hmm
rook a5
seven okay King h8 h TG 6 yeah it's not
that easy to find to find a way into
blacks position despite the fact that it
looks like you're very very close to
check meeting him probably though you
don't have enough pieces and I do have
quite quite a few defenders around my
king the knight being especially a very
strong defender around the king
so after H 2 G 6 9 XG 6 Queen - II - he
must have forgotten about the bishop on
f4 right because after night except for
I think it's finally time to resign no
no no resignation Queen takes you that's
the problem you're losing too many
pieces you're losing all your pieces
you're not losing only that the bishop
on f4 ah Ruchi want ok ok he was a kind
of committing suicide throwing his
pieces at his opponent hoping that I
don't know black we'll just forget about
playing chess
maybe it was a blitz game I'm not sure
no it says rated classical game okay
rook Jiwon is a bit disrespectful I have
to admit if I would see what you want I
would be like are you really still
playing
yeah I mean everything wins everything
wins absolutely everything wins but
obviously I mean Quinton she won has to
win a little bit faster than that just
eliminate all the pieces from the board
III assume so I I think so
yeah I think he was trying to be cute
Queen takes you one okay and finally we
have the resignation there's there's no
more pieces to throw at your opponent
then I think Bishop b5 is just simply
coming with a lot of choice yeah
checkmates in a couple of moves so that
was a viewers choice
thank you for watching and we'll see you
next week
[Music]
you
[Music]